you
okay let's give computer impossible
another try here this is a 10/2 game
French defense the last time I played
against it I was white so let's see how
this one turns out had this position
many times against it before not
necessarily why I was recording but
usually establishes upon on e5 you know
King side fee and keto I'm gonna play
Bishop to e7 so I don't have to worry
about any fork with e5 this will happen
soon I'm not so sure I want to Castle
kingside because I would fall under
maybe some attack so I wonder if I could
retain a little bit of flexibility here
I'm thinking about Queen c7 and maybe
getting some Queen side development in
working on getting this guy working hmm
you know I'm gonna I'm not so sure I
know where I want my Queen just yet so
let's go with b6 b6 Bishop to b7 and I
could still fall off with this let's see
if a 5 is gonna be played now hmm so
this is a bit interesting I wonder if I
should castle now or still delay King
side development our King side castling
queenside on yelets still stay a bit
flexible b5 ona play Knight d7 so this
is certainly different different look
from the computer here from what I'm
used to
usually it's already playing e5 so how
much more can i really delay castling i
can go in either direction here hmm it
usually gets to a point where you you
know if you're trying to remain flexible
you run out of useful moves and i think
i'm close to that point so i kinda have
to get on with just getting some
development and i wonder if i should
consider caps
ring first and then kingside castling
hmm you know what this last move Bishop
f4 is on the cards gaining a tempo
against my queen hmm I won't be I was
thinking for a moment to capture on e4
and after the recapture then I'm in a
position to me Bishop f4 with e5 but
that's probably not a good choice this
night's gonna be quick to make use of d5
if I'm ever pushing like this
what other candidate moves are there
here I really go Queen side that's why
sure I'm a fan of queenside castle as
kid this Bishop here is gonna be a
fantastic defender White's King side in
some race against one anothers King and
he's gonna be he's gonna be really good
I think I should run with King side
castling now least I got some quick
Queen side development in should e5 be
played but I'm expecting Bishop f4 and
no how do you like that okay hmm my
first thought is to take with the night
not just so Bishop f4 doesn't come with
tempo but I want to keep this diagonal
open let's go with this plus I want to
kind of keep this structure as is okay
hmm but happy to see this move to be
honest if I do take I'm helping white to
develop but I still want to do that
because I want to have my rook my Queen
rook quickly placed on the D file so
that I could meet Bishop f4 with Queen
here and I'm staying well coordinated
with my rooks okay hmm
I think I have to be a bit prepared for
a d5 break this point is something I
could try to pile up on that's for sure
my queen on c7 is unprotected so
something like I play a flight square d4
pawn takes take with the pond then maybe
I have some problem here
clean being unprotected there is maybe
some tension between our Queens at some
stage hmm I don't know that I could
really do anything great against d3 I'm
just trying to prepare right now if this
at this stage for some pawn break the d4
break is the only one that I'm seeing in
that position you know I may still just
run with this let's just consider h6 d4
pawn takes if pawn takes pawn I don't
think I have any issues with like Queen
d7 I think that should be fine let me
get a useful move in here a flight
square let's see what white comes up
with okay so some slow improving type of
things here going on so I'm improving
those Bishop f6 I imagine is pretty good
hmm I'd like to trade light square
bishops I'm Bishop f6 I wonder if
there's going to be Knight d2 to c4 or
e4 hmm if Bishop f6 Knight d2 I'd like
to move my knight but I think 94 is
gonna be a bit of a bug threatening to
then take my bishop with check maybe
right now is the point where I should go
with doubling on the D file that seems
sensible let's go with it he's not doing
anything on f8 okay so there we go
dark square bishop exchange fan of that
I think let's go with the dark square
Bishop exchange let's see that Wow okay
I'm feeling pretty comfortable okay
let's go with rook or queen hmm I don't
think there's anything
with rook takes let's go with rook takes
yeah rook takes and there we go okay so
we got this little Knight maneuver I
could go to a five to make sure he's not
going to jump into sea form um
what's another idea what about 90 to 90
to stay a bit more central yeah let's go
to eat her 97 97 seems fine I'm
expecting 94 whoa okay I only have one
reply so I'm happy with that exchange
and now we got that pesky night I'm
thinking drop all the way back yeah
let's drop all the way back otherwise in
rookie 795 comes with tempo alright I
feel like this should be a pretty equal
ish position knight c6 yeah let's go
with the knight c6 Knight c6 Queen d7
Queen d5 now I could think about
starting to double again in fact let's
throw my rook up as far as it can go
if Knight here retreat then I drop back
I'm fine with that
in fact I feel like it would be some
type of repetition if I went here I
think that I might even come back here I
don't think white is any better
let's test the waters here if the knight
comes back I know that the computer
thinks it's not better okay so
about just deviling let's go with the
double and there okay so I'm gonna come
right back I'm gonna move forward any
tricks here I don't think so I have
pretty good coordination three minutes
in change
night okay pond air hmm can I get my
queen over I would really like a queen
exchange in fact I'd really like a night
exchange how can I make that happen you
know I was thinking Queen it Queen a six
but rook takes pawn then would be pretty
good getting two pieces out of my night
Queen a six this guy would be
unprotected so let's not do that maybe I
could consider knight or a King h8
although f7 is a bit soft hmm not quite
sure what about trying to kick this
night away a six and pawn push hmm that
seems like it's making some progress
let's try and make some progress here
kick this knight from his post and let's
follow through so this is a little bit
more vulnerable all right and I could
play this move b4 and try and get the d4
square I like keeping this pawn here in
fact I think hmmm what could I do here I
like keeping my pawn here kind of
offsets this Knight
I wonder this pawn how
- through if I play b4 this is gonna be
a bit sensitive huh okay I gotta try
something
what is that something gonna be I'm
gonna drop back here she is one step why
there exactly I'm not sure got a rook
exchange let's see what it does on a
rook exchange it's not okay let's room
Queen here now I've control over the d4
break okay come over in this direction
mm-hmm
pesky pesky computer okay should
probably try to contest that file he's
maybe a bit misplace let's get back over
here
rook a8 and then drop my other hook back
okay let's try this rook takes Queen
takes I'm gonna do the same I like my
knight better than oh that is so
weakening if a human player ever did
that that would it's just not good with
the Queen still so many pieces on the
board though the Queen's ready to play
to f2 and target c5 let's reprove my
Queen position she could do better
that's for sure let's get up here and
target c4 I'm sorry b3
I think c4 might be played okay I'm fine
with that takes context okay I could get
a queen exchange hmm that Knight is so
tricky though I think I do best to keep
the Queen's on the board
though it's kind of tough here there's
gonna be g4 Queens ready - sniff him and
then be on my night so Queen here I
could get the Queen's off and keep
pressure here let's try that
Queen takes Knight takes and I'm on this
okay
take here and Queen takes cream take on
my knight and then I'm on b3 okay going
for something else here clearly what
about rook here I think I have to go for
it how to defend that pawn huh what can
I do here
Queen takes Queen and then Knight here
looking to snip this guy I think I have
to go for it get my knight in here grab
this pawn alright missing it's gonna be
a check I don't see what I'm missing
I could could have even if that poem is
defend I could still take it because of
this there's no way I am worse here
there's definitely no way I'm worse
let's see let's throw some checks here
check another check pick off this guy
he's ready to get here um let's take
this pawn Knight takes I'm gonna give
this check at least I got the tricky
Knights off the board that's good news
but is this pot I'm gonna get rolling
let's try and get behind him definitely
have to try and get behind them so how
can i how can i get rolling here I got
to get a passed pawn of my own an
outside pass pawn so I'm paving the way
for that let's do know very little time
you gotta try this it's gonna be very
fast gotta keep running with this cut
the King off I think I should have a
draw here and I think that's the best I
could get hmm okay interesting so I'm
gonna be able to draw this time should
not be an issue can I win it
banks on time here it's gonna be tough
to win hmm and try and sneak my King
around a bit get this pawn here and if I
went there that would have been a check
let's try something else I'm gonna come
back to f7 let's try this the computer
could definitely still mess up here I'm
gonna try and come around on me on the H
file another check g7 h6 okay keep their
king cut off I'm expecting rook b8 at
some stage oh it didn't cover it b8
really that is a bit surprising it
should still be to draw but let's throw
in a couple more checks get some time
back hmm
I really can't make progress I have to
play rook to g8 but never I'm not really
making much progress I think this is
just a dead draw now let's just play it
out and it shouldn't mess it up I don't
think the computers gonna miss this or
not but we'll give it a shot here let's
give a check play here I guess it's
gonna give another check we'll see the
technique by the computer coming up and
it should be playing here yep that's the
draw and let's just go forward with the
rotor pass to get in some checking
distance and it does and we'll just
we'll just go into a repetition to have
this one finish like so has to keep
coming back over now and sure enough
this one's going to end as a repetition
which is better than the usual case
against this monster I almost just hit
resigned by mistake terrible man all
right I'm I'm actually happy with the
jaw there usually ends up playing e5 but
we had a different structural change
captioning on d5 and this pond here
in the day he was a bit of a liability
being on a half-open file some peace
exchanges and then this crazy f4 MO
something that you wouldn't really never
see a human do I like my position here
just doing a quick piece-by-piece
assessment
you're just having the better night
compare these guys here the rooks at the
end of the day they ended up offsetting
f4 the rooks coming off I get the d4
square but they kick my queen from that
central post wasn't enough I don't know
if I could have tried to convert that
better in the end I was up a pond but it
was still tough that a/c pond was really
tying me down I really couldn't make
much progress here at this stage my king
as soon as he tries to get active you
know if he's ever playing up here
there's that rook check and then he
promotes oh well well I'll take a draw
that's for sure and who tried 10:00 to
4:00 another time anyhow that's all for
this video and as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you